7930 allerdings müssen erreicht und eine
organische reichweite aufbauen und leute
diese werbungen vor irgendwelchen videos
oder auf instagram wo irgendwelche leute
euch erklären wollen wie man geld
verdient schmeißt sie bitte einfach
links zum fenster raus weil es einfach
der größte scheiß ist wieso sollten
diese leute euch dann sagen wie man geld
verdienen ist doch viel besser was für
sich selber behält wie man geld verdient
die verdienen nämlich ihr geld indem sie
euch sagen die man geld verdient das hat
nichts mit dem heutigen video zu tun
aber das muss ich gerade einfach mal
sagen weil wir wieder so eine dumme
werbung kam fast jetzt eine freundin
oder nicht ich kann euch jetzt wirklich
leute was genau von willkommen bei einem
neuen video leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht's gut ich habe mir für das
heutige video folgendes überlegt und
zwar wenn ich ganz stumpf gesagt man
wieder fragen beantworten
ihr habt mir wieder eine menge fragen
gestellt ganz speziell auch eine frage
auf die ich heute mal eingehen möchte
ein bisschen eigentlich ziemlich spontan
das ganze also hatte ich jetzt nicht so
wirklich geplant umsetzen tagen sich
heute dieses video machte aber wir
beantworten heute fragen
ich wünsche euch viel spaß mit dem video
und lassen doch nach oben da wenn ihr
sagt hey bei mir zu hause scheint heute
die sonne hier ist es nämlich nicht der
fall so leute dann würde ich sagen
kommen wir auch ganz flott zur ersten
frage
und die ist von marie sgp und sie fragt
hast du schon mal geklaut wenn ja was
war das tollste was du jemals geklaut
hast clowns natürlich nichts gutes aber
wenn man so zehn jahre alt ist und nur
vollidiot als freundin hat schöne grüße
an dieser stelle kommen dazu ganz blöde
ideen und auch ich habe mal geklaut
ja das kann ich alles offen sagen also
ich habe ab und zu mal so karl friesen
geklaut und sie jetzt nichts groß ist
aber wir haben früher schon ein paar
süßigkeiten gekauft die samira hat eine
ganz lange frage gestellt und zwar wie
findest du es dass mittlerweile viele
nicht alle nun auch nach dem aussehen
gehen und viel wert auf markenklamotten
legen und halt äußerlich und ach so
punkt und würdest du lieber für den rest
deines lebens von fastfood leben oder
grünem salat kannst du mich bitte grüßen
samira schöne grüße erstmal beginn
erstmal auf den ersten parteien und dazu
muss ich sagen dass ich dir natürlich
recht gebe vor allem alter wenn ich
diese videos sehe wie viel das sein
outfit werden um irgendeinen 12
sagt dass sein outfit 10.000 euro wert
ist er denn t shirt anhört für 600 euro
von gucci oder so kann ich wirklich die
welt nicht mehr verstehen wir haben hier
probleme da habe ich wirklich als
außenstehender auch ein schlechtes
gewissen anderen menschen wissen nicht
mehr wo sie etwas zu essen bekommen und
hier kaufen sich zwölfjährige t shirts
für 600 euro oder die eltern
unterstützten sie halt in dem sinne
natürlich habe ich auch viele klamotten
von irgendwelchen marken ich habe auch
in letzter zeit sehr viel her geschenkt
bekommen aber wo ich jetzt das im urlaub
war hatte ich wirklich nur namen
klamotten dabei und diesen auch geil aus
von daher legt wirklich nicht zu viel
wert auf klamotten der eine typ ist
nicht besser nur weil er eine hose anhat
für 200 euro oder soja und jeder fragt
hast du noch kontakt zu deinen alten
schul klassenkameraden wenn ja macht
noch was mit denen wir nein möchtest du
ein paar wieder sehen also das ist
natürlich immer schwer wenn sich nach
dem abitur ihr abitur gemacht die wege
trennen und die eigenen der stadt
studieren und die anderen in der aber
natürlich habe ich noch ab und zu
kontakt zu vielen leuten aus meiner
halten auf meiner alten schule oder
meine alten stufe natürlich nicht so
viel wie früher zu den einen märz unter
anderem natürlich auch gar nicht aber
das ist ja völlig normal trotzdem ist es
natürlich immer cool solche leute
wiederzusehen weil ich meine wir waren
sieben jahre oder sondergleichen
vielleicht spürt die nächste frage bitte
sie eigentlich ziemlich gut auf die
vorletzte wie viel geld gibst du im
monat für klamotten aus ich habe letzten
monat für klamotten 120 euro auszugeben
das lag aber auch nur daran weil ich
noch klamotten brauche ich einfach hier
in köln keine klamotten mehr hatte und
mir dann halt welche kaufen müsste aber
aber ich habe im letzten monat und auch
in diesem monat viele klamotten zur
verfügung gestellt bekommt für dich
nichts bezahlen muss wird hast du schon
die schule geschwänzt also habe ich
wirklich oft gemacht am ende in der
zwölften klasse war ich bei manchen
kursen gar nicht mehr einfach weil es
die lehrer nicht interessiert hat und
ich finde man muss dann auch verstehen
wenn man für für andere fächer lernt
dass man
nicht immer also natürlich ist es
vorgeschrieben da zu sein aber am ende
war ich echt oft nicht da du sagst du
gehst zur uni was studierst du herr
alexey das ist ein cooler hashtag aber
jetzt bitte alle fragen an mich auch
unter dieses video wenn irgendwelche
fragen ob der nächsten part hashtags
studiere medien und
kommunikationsmanagement ziemlich langer
name wieder da aber schon verrät geht es
um medien es geht um kommunikation
sprich werbung vermarktung von
irgendwelchen produkten und so weiter
also sowas wie die später auch sehr
gerne mal machen so kommen wir zur
absoluten master frage die natürlich
sehr sehr viele von euch hat
interessiert warum das ist für mich
immer so ein phänomen natürlich weiß ich
dass das immer leute wissen wollen ich
habe ja auch zweimal schon meine
freundinnen auf youtube gezeigt ich
meine ich bin jetzt auch schon vier
jahre auf youtube dabei oder so hast
jetzt eine freundin oder nicht ich kann
euch jetzt wirklich eine lange story
erzählen und oder was heißen story es
ist eigentlich nur meine meinung und ich
hoffe das ist okay das ist jetzt ein
bisschen länger wird es ist immer sehr
sehr schwer seine eigenen interessen
allen anderen leuten natürlich auch ihre
zuschauer ja zu verknüpfen vor allem
wenn man halt sachen unterschiedlich
sieht ich habe so viel gelernt schon auf
youtube und wenn man im video dreht hey
ich habe eine neue freundinnen zum
beispiel bei meinem letzten video das
haben so viele menschen gesehen und das
ist dann halt zum zeitpunkt des schnitts
macht und da ist alles schon ganz anders
das ist jetzt gar nicht negativ oder so
aber man wird tagtäglich mit fragen zur
beziehung konfrontiert man wird auf der
straße darauf angesprochen natürlich
auch gesehen zusammen manche machen dann
auch ein foto so was halt ich weiß nicht
so sieht ist dieser freundinnen hype
egal ob es jetzt auf instagram oder oder
youtube ist ist halt echt krass und das
problem ist dass können wahrscheinlich
viele von euch gar nicht so wirklich
nachvollziehen wenn ich sage das ist mir
wichtig dass das vielleicht nicht jeder
weiß wobei sich das dann auch viel
leichter anhört wenn man sagt ich
verheimliche meine freundin ja das ist
so so schwer auf lange zeit und marie
ist ja selbst oft in meinen videos dabei
und eigentlich kann man da auch nur
eine meinung zu haben zu dem thema weil
das eigentlich schon offensichtlich ist
trotzdem möchte ich versuchen hier auf
meinem hauptkanal das nicht so
ja so so zu fokussieren wie das letzte
mal einfach weil ich finde dass es geht
halt sehr stark in die privatsphäre und
und wenn ich jetzt mit hinblick auf die
letzten jahre abwägen würde ist mir
deshalb sehr wichtig seine privatsphäre
und ich hoffe das war steht hier auf und
was halt auch noch dann stark in die
karten spielt sag ich mal ist das halt
nicht jede person so für diese online
präsenz gemacht ist ja da gibt es welche
die denken erst ist es cool und sind
dann 40 total in der öffentlichkeit und
dann ist es halt so dass es plötzlich
viel zu viel was ich sagen kann ich bin
zu 100 prozent super glücklich und wenn
es dann bald mal an der zeit ist dass
man halt mal über sachen reden kann
zusammen und so dann kann man natürlich
auch mal ein video zu dem thema machen
aber gerade sage ich halt einfach noch
das ist alles so wie es ist
und schaut gerne auf dem rhein kanal von
marion mir vorbei weil das sind super
coole videos und es halt einfach ein
anderer kanal so dass wir jetzt genug
drumherum gelaber wir kommen zur
nächsten frage was sind fünf plus 5 x 5
ganz einfach 30.4 strich ins marlon ich
sehe voll auf facebook dass da so steht
was ist 3 + 3 x 3 und einfach so viele
leute schreiben falsche antworten wie
findest du das neue album von showman
dass du das kenne ich gar nicht
[Musik]
ist jetzt nicht zu 100 prozent meine
musik aber er hat sich ganz cool
nun würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
werden alexei fragt durftest du jetzt
eigentlich mal bei mcdonalds burger
arbeiten leider immer noch nicht
ich habe auch in letzter zeit jetzt
nicht mehr so wirklich nachgefragt aber
ich würde das natürlich super super
gerne machen deswegen wenn ihr mir einen
gefallen tun wollt dann spam mal
mcdonald's voll egal ob auf twitter
facebook oder sonst wurde mein ding auch
per mail
haye der alex wie ist ein supercooler
youtuber der würde mega gerne mal wir
euch probearbeiten meldet euch doch mal
bei dem und dann kriegen wir das
bestimmt hin
da brauche ich eure unterstützung jetzt
macht schreibt in die kommentare hashtag
probearbeiten wenn ihr mcdonald's
irgendwo kontaktiert habe das würde mich
sehr freuen
und das war jetzt mal wieder eine menge
fragen und das ist eigentlich auch schon
wieder mit dem video checkt auf jeden
fall ins netz oder abwesend vermutlich
morgen wieder und ich hoffe ihr könnt
das verstehen was ich eben euch erklärt
habe genau also wir sehen uns morgen
wieder haut rein